for the candid responses let's start
with money
um
very simply
just give a number ideally how much
money should your man make a year
Heather
eight figures eight figures ideally okay
so that's ten million dollars yeah
minimum I do okay ideally gotcha so I
mean ideally or realistically you asked
let's go realistically since ideally is
so you want to date
yeah you want to date an NBA player but
like the best NBA player because most
NBA players make like 3 million you want
to date the quarterback for the Miami
Dolphins no I don't do that or you want
to date the CEO of Amazon all right so
athletes are out yeah athletes are out
okay so athletes are out so all your 10
million always or is this a new
um it's I've dated athletes and it's
just not my thing so I've tried it and
it's just personal preference anything
against you guys so ideally respect 10
million [__] [__] by the way what
percentage of men do you think make 10
million dollars a year I'm sure it's a
very small give it give me a number
I'm not good with the numbers yeah
one through ten I mean you one through
ten I mean one through 100 like
percentage it's probably like a tenth of
a percentage
one percent
all right you got this thing girl
um okay that's ideally realistically I
think six figures okay minimum yeah
gotcha all right
respect so you just went from a hundred
thousand you went from 10 million to 100
Grand okay well I'm just you said
ideally who doesn't want ideally the
most amount come on
girl
ideally slash realistically how much
money should your man make a year
um I think I'd
like devendi 70 80. no that's ideal no
no no
lose my number homie you wear like our
girls on my show say this all the time
like six figures up like I have never
thought I was gonna date a guy that made
six figures why I don't you make six
stages now more than six figures yeah so
don't you want to give your kids the
life that you've had
um we we grew up pretty Frugal like we
made a lot of money but we like you had
a slide in your backyard oh yeah that's
true
I grew up on fuel assistance and Welfare
there's a very big time going to the
pool or just onto grass in the pond
that is the sign of wealth right there
because a slide just onto the grass you
do Sports you've been able to travel
there's a lot of things that your family
like has been able to provide 70k like
it's hard to send your kids even on an
AAU team yeah okay so the question is uh
because are you getting that number
because there's a there's a a study out
there that says seventy thousand dollars
is the Baseline that creates happiness
and anything above that is more
materialism and consumerism is that
where you're getting that number I got
the number because it's a little more
than what I used to make at my sales job
okay so it's just like that's what I
used to make like roughly 50k okay so
you said ideally like honestly when I
was just thinking the same job that I
used to have have interesting I mean
like what would you say to someone who's
saying Pearl you're crushing it right
now I assume you're making way more than
seventy thousand what would you say to
the people out there that it's like come
on Pearl you're selling yourself short
do better
you are I mean how do I put it like
sure if that if that happened like great
I just don't think it's like that
realistic I mean it's such a small
percentage of guys that make that much
money like I think I think it would be
unrealistic of me to think oh this guy
has to make more money than me okay well
I'm gonna give you some numbers in a
second as far as like what men make and
what percentage of men make but let's go
down the line here and then I'll give
you some numbers ideally slash
realistically how much you want your man
to make ideally we're on the same page
ideally I would like yeah like a
successful entrepreneur
um who is making more money than me we
did discuss because we were on the
pre-game so tune in to her podcast
um what like my lowest would be and I
think I said 120 or 150. okay
um so minimum basis six figure man
minimum yeah okay how about you Emily
ideally I love where my ladies heads are
at let's be a little delusional you know
I'd say at least 10 million you know
what [__] it let's make it 50 ml a
yearly so you guys
you guys are comfortable with being
delusional absolutely I'm not delusional
I've dated a guy whose house was eight
figures okay so I mean it's just
you're not delusional because you've
done it before have you ever done dating
a guy who makes 10 million a year oh
please I've dated brokies
so maybe you're delusional and she's not
yeah and you're embracing that also
delusional honey wow okay so so
realistically yes realistically
realistically I think on Pearl's podcast
we did talk about this minimum for if
it's a single family provider I would
want my husband to be making
120 150 around there got it okay so
there's realistically we're in the six
figures 70k category
delusional status I meet this guy making
eight figures 10 20 million bucks a year
okay now if that guy
makes 10 20 million dollars a year let's
go there for a second
uh how comfortable would you be if he
cheated on you every once in a while not
all the time
but once a year Heather I love you baby
but I'm going on a business trip by the
way I made 10 million dollars this year
so you like your you like you like your
G wagon that you're driving you like the
mansion that's how it is I agree that is
how it is but there's you know it's
there's a payoff for everything so you
are comfortable with it I'm not
comfortable with it it's not ideal if
we're speaking idealistically but once a
year you'll deal with it though
if I'm driving a G wagon I'd rather I'd
rather drive
so once a year what about 10 times a
year about once a month I mean it all
depends on the situation he's now making
20 million dollars a year
you have two g-wagons
one for you and one for your assistant
sure
okay guys make your [__] money you'll
date Miss Montana cheat on her as much
as you want but you got to make 10 to 20
million dollars a year yeah I would get
an allowance I would be like put money
in stocks for me like start a company
for me like little things on the side
where I'm making money and then you
cheat on me now flip it the dude making
70 grand a year or even 100 Grand a year
no he's not allowed to cheat on you no
that guy will treat you better so it's
it's going to treat you better the guy
that makes less money so would you
rather would you rather it's false would
you rather
the guy that makes a buck 20 a year but
treats you great doesn't cheat on you
respects you or the guy that makes 10
million dollars a year probably treats
you okay but definitely cheats on you
but you're driving a G-Wagon just
because he is which would you pick I
mean it depends on the guy I ideally I
want somebody that I can have fun with
that's really important to me that we
get along because I view marriage as you
know it's a 50-year long conversation so
if you're somebody that I can have a
good conversation with that's what's
most important to me so if we can have
fun together have a good conversation
travel and just have a good time that's
my priority so it depends on the person
wow that was beautiful this is why men
need to make money because Girls Just
Want to Have Fun Fun costs money
men need to make money because men want
women
and women want fun but they're making
cost money and guys need to make money
because men want women and women want
fun and phone costs money and that's
just how it goes we're gonna do a
whiteboard episode on that right yeah
Girls Just Want to Have Fun you saying
what were you saying about the the oh we
were talking about how delusional you
are continue
you're saying that the guy that makes 10
20 million he could do whatever he wants
can he do any wrong you can cheat on you
anything oh he's the last to be
accountable to me I'm sorry he's giving
you an allowance and you're driving a G
wagon why is he still accountable and
and he's getting this and I'm raising
his children so he's getting that [__]
so would you have like a magical [__]
that like has leprechauns like I
honestly
[Music]
she knows what Rich problems come with I
think ideally no one wants anyone it's
not a unicorn I think a lot of women
would put up with it but this is like
the cognitive dissonance that I think
men have a problem with right so here
you are you got freaking Miss USA over
here miss Montana I mean I think you
should have won but I think it was
stolen from you however so on one hand
you want a guy that you can have fun
with that treats you right but you also
want a guy that makes 10 million dollars
a year ideally and you're acknowledging
the fact that if you're making 10
million bucks yeah I get it you're gonna
have you know More Money More Problems
but maybe that guy would treat you
better but he doesn't make enough money
does it just come down to Lifestyle that
like are women I guess Pro my question
to you is are are women realistic with
the lifestyle that they really want
versus what is the ideal lifestyle that
they actually probably need what are
your thoughts realistic with the
lifestyle yeah like these women are
obsessed with not this woman but women
are obsessed with the lifestyle I've
heard you talk about this before what
are your thoughts on that well yeah I
don't I mean Women Marry a lifestyle I
mean because I mean who's the first one
gone when he loses his job her that's
like one of the number one indicators
that you're gonna get divorced is if he
loses his job so that's why they say
like women can't love in the same way
that like men can love because once you
lose what you have like a lot of times
women leave
this is such a true this is such a good
point out there but why men fall in love
like ideally like ideologically like
romantically because they there's no
strings attached I don't care baby like
I don't care what you do I don't care
what you make I don't care where your
career is I love you whereas women are
like I love you but I also love your
Mansion your house your cars even if you
have kids or whatever and I think ideal
lifestyle and I think the older a woman
gets the harder it is for her to
genuinely love like there are some girls
that are ride or dies right there are
but they're but I just have noticed they
tend to be that way if they met their
man young and like the more trauma like
a girl's gone through I just think it's
harder for her as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible